of the council
and
first of all i'd like to remind you of
some of the domestic arrangements
the toilets are situated outside the
meeting room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by default by
following the far exit signs and meet on
the ipswich town football club training
page
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record
film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
let us move to the agenda
[Applause]
item number one is election of chairman
of the council
please can i have nominations for the
position of chairman of the council
councilor morley
thank you chair yes i would like propose
councillor castin
as chair of the council james has been a
well-regarded member
of the uh of our councillors
for eight almost eight years now seven
years
um he's diligent
enthusiastic
and
would make a fine chairman
thank you chair thank you councillor do
i have a proposal on secondary
council
okay thank you
right i will now ask the corporate
nominations manager i'll be your pardon
i've missed a bit
uh right are there any further
nominations counselor melon
thank you mr chairman um i would like to
nominate councillor john field
for the position of chairman of the
council
as i'm sure members will be aware
counselor field has been a counsellor
since way back in 2001 and has
represented his community
at both district and county so it brings
a lot of experience in local
government to the role
and outside of council he has a wealth
of knowledge from his career in business
although he rarely mentions that
another qualification that he brings to
the current situation is he's not a
member of the largest two parties
not not a green not a conservative so he
could bring an important neutrality to
the role of chairman and lastly since i
understand that this may well be his
last year as a council i think it would
be a fitting end to his long career if
he was to serve as chairman for this
next year so i'm very happy to nominate
councillor john field and ask
councillor eberton to second the
nomination
councillor
thank you chair i'd be happy to second
thank you thank you very
much
right i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair i'm going to take the
first nomination and if that nomination
pulls over 50 of the people who are here
tonight we would declare that person is
duly elected so um could you place your
vets but votes please
[Laughter]
thank you
yes
thousands
um
councillor whalum are you having
problems do you want to place your vote
man
okay thank you
so chair that is 17 votes 4 and 13
against so that is carried
[Applause]
sorry
so i declare councillor casten duly
elected and
if i
vacate the chair for the last time this
season
i'd like to kind of say a sort of a
hello
thank you and goodbye
first of all excuse me if i stand up i
need to look at my notes um i'd like to
congratulate councillor castle on being
elected
i'm sure that he will do a fine job he's
a fine gentleman and i'm sure he'll be
even handed in his approach to how he
deals with chairing the council meetings
and
then i'd like to thank a few people um
starting with
um karen sayer who's our civic officer
who's not here this evening
many of you may recall or not as a case
may be that in fact karen started a
civic officer just when i was elected
chairman so her and myself have been
muddling through
in terms of our civic duties and i think
we've done reasonably well and i
congratulate karen on on what she's done
i think she's done a fine job i think
she's been very supportive and helped me
through that element of my job
and um
in fact you know given the circumstances
i think that we were very happy that i
was able to go to the east england
children's hospice this afternoon and
present them with a check for
1565 pounds
[Applause]
secondly i'd like to record my thanks to
jen robinson
who has shown a remarkable patience and
politeness in
guiding me through the different council
meetings
even when i'm trying to make a complete
hash of it and um you know we are very
lucky to have someone like jan
who is the backbone of this meeting and
i do really appreciate and thank you for
your help and support
and that also goes for mandy who kind of
sits there in the background doing all
the i.t stuff and you know someone has
to do it and someone has to do it well
and she does do it well
then i guess that i would like to extend
further thanks
to the sport i've had from emily and
arthur who have at the appropriate
moment intervened on constitutional
matters
even while i was trying to not drown
because i didn't know what the next
score was
so really appreciate it and
i'm sure you'll do the same for james
going forward
and finally council i'd like to thank
all of you for your support and
perseverance during my year of office
it's been a pleasure a challenge and a
very interesting experience to have been
your chairman and i thank you all very
much indeed and wish you well under
james's tutelage thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much everyone
i counselor james caston having been
duly elected to the office of chairman
of mid-suffolk district council
declare that i take
that office upon myself and will duly
and faithfully fulfill the duties of it
in accordance to my best judgment and
ability
i undertake that in before
in performing the functions of chairman
i shall observe the code of conduct as
adopted by the council and i'll now sign
the document
right i'd just like to say a few words
thank you
firstly i'd like to thank councillor
morley for my nomination and councillor
hadnam for my second and for their kind
words
it was very humbling to hear them i
would also like to thank my fellow
councillors for supporting me it is an
honour to be elected as chairman
secondly i would like to thank the
outgoing chairman councillor eppinyon
councillor eppinyong took the chair in
the dark days of covert 19 and served
with distinction throughout the previous
municipal year
he has been an excellent example to me
of how the duty should be carried out
and is done so faultlessly
the chairmanship is a tremendous honor
it is a neutral role on the council and
a great tradition i'm proud that
everyone in front of me has made a
decision to help guide the future
and deal
with the issues of residents who number
between 1700 to nearly 5 000 residents
in some multi-member wards and then
beyond this some 84 000
residents in the district as a whole
as councillors we are constantly drawing
on the work of our parish councils
community groups and residents for
confirmation that we are dealing with
matters in the right way
this work is not an easy task but none
of the members of this council took that
easy option
it works well because every member has
their own unique belief and
understanding that feeds through to
their fellow councillors changing the
council's understanding
sometimes slightly sometimes greatly
that is why i stand here addressing a
body that is always evolving and more
complex and intelligent than the sum of
its paths
and i know that every contribution and
decision is made with the true belief
that it makes mid-suffolk better
without the senior leadership team
officers and staff now working here at
home and in stone market this could not
be done the competence and quality of
their work
i find really impressive
they are the muscles and circulatory
system pumping life through this
impressive beast of an organization
in my view everyone in this chamber
shares the same fundamental goals
they want to reduce hardship and
suffering
and
remove barriers preventing residents
from being healthy and content whilst
building the best sustainable future for
mid-suffolk
a collective goal but what sometimes
divides us is the difference in the
argument of how we achieve this
i admire this great system of local
government like
i have said instead of 34 people i stand
in front of thousands of people being
represented in this chamber and that is
the true beauty of democracy in this
country
my goal of as chair is to understand and
serve
every member in this council
to make sure that administration is
given the best platform to serve the
district
at
district on and just as importantly the
opposition are given the platform to
serve to scrutinize
their values are equal in measure
now i would like to talk a little bit
about my chosen charity
for my chairman's charity i have chosen
stone marker asd saturday clubs
this incredible charity provide correct
and supportive environments for five to
eleven year olds with autism
it gives these youngsters
a safe place where they are free to be
themselves whilst at the same time
building social skills and developing
friendships
parents and
guardians are encouraged to leave the
child with the club whilst the child is
accessing new activities
the parent or guardian has a chance to
get away from asd
to do things that are difficult to do
with an autistic child
sometimes it is important to spend time
with a sibling of that child and help
stop them from feeling marginalized
sometimes to rest from a challenging
environment
the club is run by parents and guardians
of the members and paid members of staff
with trustees overseeing the running it
is so important for autistic children to
have a space in which they are allowed
to be autistic
and embrace their positive qualities
i chose this charity after a
conversation with councillor terence
carter where he explained the
complexities and challenges of parenting
an asd
child
this led me to contact one of my very
good friends who has an autistic child
i asked her which charities helped her
do
helped her and do an amazing job and
stomach at asd saturday clubs was the
one she told me about
i'm sure you will all support me in
raising money and awareness for this
special charity
i look forward to this municipal year
to observe the action from the chair and
i am grateful to everyone for this
opportunity i will do this to the best
of my ability and judgment
thank you very much
[Applause]
right so
i'd like to um move to item number two
election of vice chairman of the council
may i have nominations for vice chair of
the councillor councillor flatman
thank you chair
i'd like to propose councillor epiglon
it would be a real shame to let all that
practice go to waste
and i think he would be an absolute
wealth of experience and help james
through it when he can't attend
different um functions thank you do i
have a seconder
councillor hattingham
thanks i'm happy to second that
thank you
are there any further nominations
councilman mellon
yes thank you mr chair and welcome to
your new role congratulations
uh i'd like to nominate councillor
roland warboys to be the vice chairman
of the council
roland as many of us know is was a
teacher he taught my three children at
stockland high school and also he's
someone who's very much rooted
uh in his community and in in the ward
that he represents
i'm sure members will also be aware of
his keen interest
in cricket
and i'm sure as vice chairman of the
council he would play a straight bat and
support the chairman in his role so very
happy to nominate council of war boys
and i call upon councillor field to
second the nomination thank you chad
councillor field
thank you
we will now get asked the corporate
manager governments and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair
um i have a nomination the first
nomination for councillor epping yong if
you can cost your votes please
councilman amoroson i notice that you're
not quite logged in can i take your vote
manually please
yes thank you
it is showing in blue so i think it is
slow sorry
chair that is 17 4 and 14 against so
that is carried
oh sorry
jump in the gun
and
invite councillor eppinyong to
declare his office
i counselor paul et having been duly
elected to the office of vice chairman
of mid suffolk district council
declared that i take that office upon
myself and will duly and faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
i undertake that in performing the
functions of vice chairman i shall
observe the code of conduct as adopted
by the council
let's go
i'd just like to um
thank councillor
flatman and my second uh counselor
hattingham for their support and their
words of well council flatman's words of
wisdom which i shall try very hard to
live up to and i should certainly do my
best to support councillor casting in
his role as chairman as well as anything
else he would like me to do for him to
help him through his year thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillors
norris and councillor pratt
thank you very much and item 4
declarations of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
no
so
item five to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 21st of march 2022
for accuracy only are there any issues
with accuracy
can i have a proposal for those minutes
councillor hadnam
thank you chair i'm happy to propose the
minutes
could i have a second uh
councillor ebern
thank you i'm happy to second that thank
you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct a
vote by show of hands
chair thank you chair so all of those in
favor if you could raise your hands
please
that's carried thank you
item six chairman's announcements
i refer you to paper mc22 to be noted
item 7 leaders announcement i would like
to invite councillor morley to present
her update
thank you chair
as always i want to highlight some of
the fantastic things the council has
been delivering since we last met
but i also want to begin by
acknowledging how wonderful it is to be
able to hold our annual council meeting
in our own council chamber with so few
covered restrictions
i say few because whilst it is great
to see some sense of normality has
returned
we must always be mindful that kovid
hasn't suddenly just disappeared
the arrival and spread of monkey pox is
perhaps a useful reminder of how quickly
such things can spread
in humans in today's society
and more importantly though there are
still those in our communities in
mid-suffolk
and in our own cohort of councillors who
are more vulnerable and so it is our
duty to continue to try and keep
everyone safe and well
i want to begin by again by reiterating
our thoughts and support for the people
of ukraine
i know we have consistently done this at
our council meetings and i know we are
all united in this regard
i feel it is vitally important though
that we continue to ensure that the war
remains in the spotlight and at the
front of our minds
suffolk as a whole and mid-suffolk in
particular is playing its part
as the public sector in welcoming and
supporting those refugees who are
fortunate enough to have escaped and
come here and i also want to pay tribute
to the generosity and compassion of our
residents
who have flung open their homes and
whole communities to our ukrainian
friends
and some of our councillors are amongst
that number so thank you
away from the national stage
and of far less importance in the grand
scheme of things
it was wonderful to be at the opening of
the duck and teapot at needham lake
it is unbelievable to think that this is
the delivery of a 20-year ambition for
the town
although we wouldn't have wished the
provider there to have been overwhelmed
in their first week
it is a really positive sign of the
support and level of demand that so many
people have flocked there
i know the provider has made changes to
be able to cater for the level of demand
and will especially be increasing
capacity for the forthcoming bank
holiday
absolutely vital to this new facility is
not just the catering aspect of course
but also the brand new changing places
facilities
and it is wonderful news that we be we
have been successful in our bid to
secure funding for two more changing
places facilities at the food museum in
stone market and at stradbroke swimming
pool and fitness centre
this is of course in addition to the
over one million pounds that we've paid
across to 49 towns and parishes in april
from the community infrastructure levy
to ensure other vital local
infrastructure continue can continue to
be improved or added across
mid-southwark other major news since we
last met was the start of infrastructure
works at gateway 14.
i was immensely proud to be asked to put
the first spade in the ground on site on
behalf of all of you
i will not go on now about how wonderful
gateway 14 will be for our residents for
employment for skills for stone market
for the whole district and for the wider
freeport area but this is our largest
single investment in recent years
as mid-suffolk
to deliver to directly deliver an
economic stimulus that will build a
thriving and more sustainable future for
our residents
i know we are all looking forward to
celebrating the next milestones in this
project as the site begins to take shape
gateway 14 however doesn't sit alone and
is of course part of our wider strategic
approach
particularly to restarting and regrowing
our local economy following the pandemic
and i would like to echo councillor
brewster's words as he launched our
economic recovery plan last month
where he said our ambition is to support
strong growth across the district
to encourage innovation and creativity
to upskill our communities and help
stimulate a wide range of job
opportunities
to achieve this we need to continue
building strong working relationships
with a range of partners
encouraging investment connecting our
communities and promoting our towns and
villages as places that want to call
that people want to call home
one key aspect of our economy in this
region is energy with bacton size will
and offshore will wind as well as an
increasing number of local energy
schemes it is hard not to see us as
powering the nation
and of course energy and in particularly
energy prices have become international
news over recent months
whilst the energy itself is important so
too is how that electricity is
transported
as you will know we are currently being
consulted as part of national grid's
east anglia green energy in enablement
project
which is a proposal to build a a new
high voltage network reinforcement
between norwich bramford and tilbury
this is just the first stage of
consultation on this project
but it has the potential to have a
significant impact on large swathes of
our district
as such i've already been engaging with
our local mp dr dan porter and i was
really pleased that we were able to
provide a briefing for all of our towns
and parishes earlier this week
cabinet is due to consider the issue in
detail on monday the 6th of june on
behalf of the council
however i do not believe this is nor
should be a party political matter and
as such i have ensured that there will
be the opportunity
for all councillors to speak and help
shape the council's response to the
consultation at that meeting
having said that i do not want to
preempt that debate i do also feel it is
safe to say that many of us and our
communities
believe that the best option would be
for the power to be transported under
the sea rather than across the land
and i'm looking forward to having the
fuller discussion on the 6th of june
in the meantime although it is unusual
to single out individual officers for
praise at council meetings
i would like to take this opportunity to
put on public record our thanks to bron
curtis
whose expertise and professionalism in
all things relating to energy and
planning
continues to be invaluable to us
thank you bron
of course i can't talk about energy
without also mentioning the cost of
living crisis
i'm hopeful that during the course of
today whilst writing my speech the
council the chancellor will have had
announced a further package of support
for those most in need
going beyond the payments of 150 pound
which we are already administering for
those in council tax bans a to d
in addition to that though we have just
published our own draft emergency
five-point plan
to help tackle the crisis over the next
six months
this again is due to be debated at the
same cabinet meeting on 6th of june
and i would encourage as many of you as
possible to attend to ask questions
and finally on a much lighter and more
celebratory note we of course have the
queen's jubilee and bank holidays next
week
there are a plethora of activities going
on across the district and the bunting
will be out everywhere
i know you will all want to promote the
celebrations happening in your wards
both next week and as part of the wider
festival of suffolk throughout the year
and i hope you will also be able to join
me roadside following cabinet on the 6th
of june to cheer on the cyclists as the
woman's tour once again flies through
mid-suffolk
thank you chair
thank you councilman
[Applause]
are there any questions for councillor
morley on
items mentioned in her announcements
councillor mellon
hey thank you chair just a quick
couple of clarifications um
it's interesting to hear the word
plethora in the speech it doesn't come
along very often and
it means a lot to me
um
couple of questions then uh
on this issue of east anglia green which
has really um stirred up our communities
a lot i i'm very grateful for the
opportunity for affected members to
come and speak at um
a account a cabinet
those who can't make that meeting will
they be able to send in written
representations
and and secondly
whether the representation is are verbal
or written
will they will they be able to amend
what the council is going to respond to
the consultation thank you
thank you councillor mellon councillor
morley
everybody has the opportunity of putting
in their own written representations
um online i believe it's online um
independently of the council
so um that is the way forward for
everybody
thank you any further questions
councillor matheson
thank you chair yes um it might seem
like semantics but can i ask um the
leader and indeed all members and
officers uh if you could refer to
russia's war um rather than emphasizing
ukraine um
because
these things actually gradually absorb
into the public consciousness and
if we get the
blame in the right place by starting
with the right word it's it's helpful
thank you
thank you
councillor stringer
sorry to be pedantic check could i could
i ask the leader to clarify her
clarification regarding the east anglia
green proposal
you you said within your speech that
members could come to cabinet to help
shape our response but then you said
that members should go online
to respond to national grid so
i was elected to this council and i
would like to be able to influence our
response can i have clarity that that
will be afforded
councillor mauling
as i've just said you are very welcome
to attend cabinet
on the 6th of june where we will be
debating it and you will be allowed to
speak
thank you any further questions
then we'll move on with the agenda
item eight designation of committees and
joint committees to appoint the
following committees and joint
committees the overview and scrutiny
committee
the development control committee a
development control committee b
planning referrals committee
licensing and regulatory committee
joint audit and standards committee and
the joint appointments committee
could i have a proposal to appoint all
committees listed in the agenda
councillor richardson i'm happy to
propose thank you chair
thank you do i have a seconder
thank you councillor morley
councillor
mansell uh thank you chair i'd just like
to ask a question uh before this uh goes
to whatever next stage it has
um and maybe the monitoring officer can
answer the question for me um at which
meeting do we determine the terms of
reference of each of these committees
thank you
chairman i'm happy to answer that
question the terms of reference are set
out in the constitution and if those
were to be amended it would come to full
council for approval
thank you very much i have a proposal
and a second i will ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue if um councils could cast their
vote thank you
um chair it is it does appear to be
going slow but it is now actually
started so you should if you just
persevere should be able to
just take up my hands up so if you ask
with people in flavor
i think this is the easiest version um
we're going to take this by show of
hands
could you please um oh sorry i love you
okay
um could you please um say this is the
designated designation of committees and
joint committees to agree the
designation of committees as detailed in
the agenda those four can you please put
your hands up
thank you that's unanimous so that's
carried
right item nine on the agenda
is
mc223
political balance and composition of
committees i refer you to appendix b in
the table papers i would like to invite
emily yule monitoring officer to
introduce the paper mc223
thank you chairman i'm pleased to
introduce this report which first asks
the council to
agree the number of seats and the
political composition of each committee
and then to agree the council is to be
appointed to those committees
which is in your table papers thank you
could i have a proposal please
counselor melon yeah happy to propose to
you
could i have a seconder
councillor muller
are there any questions on this
councillor whitehead
thank you could i just request that in
terms of the modern.gov
voting up it presently says to agree
recommendations as detailed in report bc
22 3. that could be
revised please
yes that is a typo so we can confirm
that should be emcee
and it's now correct thank you
councillor whitehead
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
councillor hicks can i just propose that
if the system's really slow tonight and
bearing in mind the amount of votes
we've got
how do we overcome that by maybe going
to vote by hands is that possible
because if each vote is going to take
five minutes we're going to be you know
we're going to have a very drawn out
evening
so unless anyone massively objects that
that councillor hicks is um chairman's
discretion so if this
vote doesn't work promptly we will go to
a show of hands
for the rest of the meeting or until the
problems solved
right
thank you very much we're going to
conduct this vote by show of hands now
so um
we the
the reckon to agree the recommendation
2.1 to 2.2 as detailed in report mc223
can i have hands four please
thank you that's unanimous so that's
carried
item 10
election of chairs and vice chairs of
committees
to elect a chair and vice chair for the
following committees
mid-suffolk overview and scrutiny
committee
development control committee a
development control committee b
mid-suffolk licensing and regulatory
committee
and also to elect co-chairs for the
following joint committees
joint audit and standards committee
joint appointments committee
may i have a nomination for chair of
overview and scrutiny committee please
councillor mellon
uh thank you chair i'm happy to nominate
councillor keith welland for that role
thank you
thank you and do i have a second
councillor morley
are there any further nominations
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct a
vote
of hands
thank you chair all those in favour
that's unanimous
[Applause]
oh
just one second
councillor wellam is julia appointed as
chair of ovn scrutiny committee thank
you
so
may i have nominations for vice chair of
overview and scrutiny committee
councillor
mellon
thank you chair i'd like to nominate
councillor keith scarf for the vice
chair thank you
do i have a seconder
thank you councillor field
are there any further nominations
councillor muller
thank you chair i'd like to
recommend yourself
for that long thank you
thank you very much do i have a seconder
counselor guthrie
thank you very much so at this point
um i would have to oh no i
yeah you can't decide at your own
election but this but this vote will be
on the um
on the first one won't it so would i
preside over that well i
um all those that in so we which advice
your partner
right so this is this is uh
one second please um counselor i i do
have to leave the room during this
so thank you
councillors so the first vote will be uh
with regards to the nomination of
councillor scarfs so and we're going to
do this by show of hands so all those in
favor please show
okay thank you
all those in favor of counts like
carsten pleision
right so that's 16 in favor of
councillor casten and uh 14 in favor of
council scarf so counter casting is due
elected to the vice chairman
i'm sure
so for the for the benefit of counselor
captain counselor you are duly elected
as vice chair foreign overview and
scrutiny
right may i have nominations for the
chair of development control committee a
councillor mayor
chair i'd like to nominate councillor
hicks an excellent job over the last
year and i look forward to extending his
tenure thank you thank you do i have a
second uh
councillor morley
do i have any further nominations
councillor mellon
yes i'm very happy to nominate
councillor sarah mansell for the chair
of development control a
do i have a seconder
councillor davies
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office
to conduct a vote by show of hands
um thank you chair um so we take the
first nomination which is councillor
hicks all of those in favor please
and thank you and all those in favor of
councillor sarah mansell
chair that is 17 votes for councillor
hicks and 14 for cancer mansell
may i have nominations for vice chair of
development control committee a
councillor muller
chair yes it gives me great pleasure to
nominate councillor barry humphreys with
his role he's done an excellent job over
the last year and i'm more than happy to
nominate him thank you chair
thank you do i have a second
councillor hadnam
thanks i'm happy to second that
do i have any further nominations
councilor mellon
yeah thank you chair i'd like to uh
nominate councillor sarah mansell for
the role of vice chair thank you
do i have a seconder
councillor davies
thank you
so i'll now ask the corporate manager
governments and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair taking the first
nomination for councillor
um
humphreys sorry i can't read my own
writing counselor humphreys um all those
in favor
thank you and all those in favor of
cancer sarah mansell
again chair that is 17 for councillor
humphreys and 14 for councilmember
councillor humphreys is duly appointed
vice chair of development control
committee a
may i have nominations for the chair of
development control committee b
councillor muller
thank you chair it's a great pleasure to
nominate councillor
kathy guthrie for this role she's done
an absolutely excellent job over the
last year more than happy to nominate
her thank you
thank you very much do i have a seconder
councillor burn
there any
other nominations counselor melon
yes thank you chair uh i'd like to put
forward uh councillor andrew stringer
for this role he's uh he has stepped in
on occasion
to chair this committee and uh strangely
enough the the sky did not fall in um so
i'm sure he could he could do a great
job here thank you
thank you do i have a seconder
councillor field
office to conduct the vote
thank you chair for taking the first
nomination for councillor guthrie all
those in favor
17
and taking the second nomination for
cancer stringer all those in favor
again that is 17 for councillor guthrie
and 14 for councillor stringer
thank you very much councillor guthrie
is duly appointed chair of development
control committee b
may i have nominations for vice chair of
development control committee b
councillor guthrie
yes thank you um i'd like to nominate
councillor muller please if i may having
been chair for many years the role has
evolved with electronic and more
complicated issues arising and as chair
you have to have eyes in the back of
your head and keep juggling having had
counsellor mueller as vice chair for the
last six months along with his
experience as member of the stone market
town council planning and his support to
me i'm more than happy to nominate him
thank you
thank you do i have a seconder
councillor hicks happy 2nd mr
thank you any other nominations
councillor mellon
yes thank you chair um i'd like to
nominate councillor stringer for the
role of vice chair of
development control b i know he's worked
very well with kathy and would support
her in her role as chair thank you
thank you do you have a seconder
counsellor omarosa
sorry i'll now ask the corporate manager
government and civic office to conduct a
vote
thank you chair for taking the first
nomination for councillor muller um all
those in favor
and all of those in favor of cancer
stringer
chair again that is 17 for councillor
muller and 14 for cancer stringer
thank you councillor muller is duly
appointed vice chair of development
control committee b
maya have no nominations for the chair
of licensing and regulatory committee
councillor fleming
she has been
chairing this committee for the past um
three years and has done a competent and
um
very successful job with it thank you
thank you do i have a seconder
councillor morley second chair
thank you are there any further
nominations councillor mellon
yes thank you chair um i'd like to
nominate councillor penny otton for the
role of uh chair of licensing regulatory
committee a very experienced councillor
and i'm sure she would bring a lot to
the role thank you
thank you do i have a secondary
council field
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair for taking the first
nomination for councillor guthrie all
those in favor
and for the second nomination councillor
otton all those in favour
chair that is 17 14 again
thank you very much councillor guthrie
is duly appointed chair of licensing and
regulatory committee
i will now
ask
oh sorry um
we have nominations for vice chair of
the licensing and regulatory committee
please
counselor guthrie
oh yes thank you very much um i would
like to propose uh councillor dave
muller
licensing is one of those mysteries and
until you're part of the group or
committee you really
need to sort of be there to see exactly
what goes on i've been happy to have
councillor muller alongside to share
what i have learned and along with his
wisdom and life's experience and support
i'm more than happy to propose
councillor muller as vice chair thank
you
thank you do we have a seconder
councillor flatman
thank you chair happy two seconds thank
you any further nominations
councillor mellon
uh yes thank you chad like to nominate
councillor penny alton for the role of
vice chair
thank you very much do we have a second
uh
counsellor mansell
thank you i'll now ask the corporate
manager governance and the civic office
to conduct the vote
thank you chair for taking the first
nomination for councillor muller all
those in favor
and all those in favor of councillor
otton
chair that is 1714.
councillor muller is duly appointed vice
chair of licensing and regulatory
committee
may i have nominations for the co-chair
of joint audit and standards committee
councillor whitehead
thank you chair i'd like to propose
council miller for this role based on
his excellent work today in his detailed
knowledge of the brief thank you
thank you very much could i have a
seconder councillor morley it's the
second lecture
are there any further nominations
councillor mellon
yeah thank you chair
i'd like to nominate councillor rachel
ebern for this role
we know that she's very experienced uh
sitting on that committee and she brings
a sort of a forensic level of detail to
that role and i'm sure she'll make an
excellent chair thank you
thank you can i have a seconder council
of war boys
i will i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the vote
thank you chair for taking the first
nomination for councillor muller all
those in favor
and the second nomination for councillor
ebern all those in favor
chair that is
1714. thank you councillor mullet is
duly elected co-chair of joint order and
standards committee
may i have nominations for the co-chair
of joint appointments committee
councillor richardson
thank you chair i would like to propose
councillor morley for the joint to be
the co-chair of the joint appointments
committee
thank you is there a seconder
councillor flatman
happy to second chair thank you are
there any further nominations
so um
okay
um i'd like to now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the vote
so for the one nomination counselor
morley all those in favor
thank you very much council morley is
julie appointed co-chair of joint
appointments committee
moving on to item 11
mc224 appointments to outside bodies for
2122
2223 i would like to invite
i refer you to appendix a in the table
papers i would like to invite the leader
to introduce paper mc224
and move the recommendation in the
report
councillor morley
thank you chair i'm happy to um
submit this uh list of outside bodies to
uh council
not sure there's anything else to say
really it's uh
that's it
so we'll um we'll take that as uh
proposed uh councillor morley's the
proposer so do we have a seconder
councillor richardson happy to second
thank you chair
right thank you
um
yeah
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair just wanted to draw
attention to the fact that that paper
was amended to remove haven gateway
partnership
and to update the food museum so
those have now been corrected and are on
the website so all of those in favor
please
thank you that's carried
item 12 appointment of councillors to
shared revenues partnership joint
committee
the nominations have been tabled
could i have a proposer
councillor eppinyon
could i have a seconder
councillor richardson
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair all those in favour
thank you that's carried
item 13 appointments to suffolk joint
standards board
the nominations have been tabled
could i have a proposal
councillor ebern
thank you chair happy to propose as per
the papers listen
thank you
can i have a second
counselor muller
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct a
vote
thank you chair all those in favor
thank you that's carried
so item 14 appointments to the joint
gypsy and travellers steering group
council is asked to appoint four
councillors to the joint gypsy and
traveller steering group the nominations
have been tabled please could i have a
proposal
councillor mansell
and their secondary
and uh secondary
councillor geek
thank you i will now ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the vote
thank you chair all those in favor
thank you that's carried
item 15 appointments to council working
groups
council is asked to appoint councillors
to the following working groups as
tabled
community governance review working
group
constitution working group
member learning and development working
group
local plan working group
could i have a proposal
counselor muller
and a seconder councillor richardson i
will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair all those in favor
so
third of june 2022 at 5 30 p.m i declare
this meeting closed
at
6 30
4.
thank you